[Música]
no
creo que todo se escuchará hablar de
mala praxis médica inmediatamente
pensamos en alguna persona a la cual le
han dejado unas tijeras o un pedazo de
gasa en el cuerpo luego una operación
pero la mala praxis médica encierra
todos aquellos errores o negligencias de
parte de cualquier personal de salud
como ya lo escucharon mi nombre es khan
adela soy estudiante del quinto año de
licra y estoy en los primeros pasos en
la carrera de medicina todavía cursando
el ingreso para hacer más claros
y la razón por la cual hoy les hablo de
esto es porque de hecho este 19 de
septiembre se cumplen tres años de que
perdí a una persona muy especial por
culpa de un error de un personal de
salud
y quieran saber qué es lo peor que este
error para ese profesional fue básico
pero fatal tanto para mi familia como
para mí
déjenme hablarles un poquito de esto
en septiembre del año 2015 en pleno
brote de dengue mi hermano mayor
sebastián que en ese entonces tenía 22
años
una tarde levanta fiebre lo primero que
hacemos es ponerle ese milagroso paño
frío sobre la frente para tratar de
bajarla pero aún así la fiebre no cede
entonces tomamos la decisión de llevarlo
a la guardia del hospital
un pequeño detalle de que no les
mencioné es que él tenía un retraso
madurativo
era una persona con capacidades
diferentes como lo dice mamá y esto
significaba que pequeños problemas en él
eran el doble de riesgosos
para hacer un poco más breve en cuanto
al relato él no solo estaba con fiebre
siempre sufre de anemia y a raíz de esto
esa noche que él lleva a la guardia con
temperatura encima lo que decía hacer el
profesional a cargo es realizar una
transfusión una transfusión de sangre no
entremos en detalle porque como recién
le dedica estoy empezando
y allí se comete el error y este error
lleva a que en un par de días tenga que
ver su nombre y su foto en una placa de
mármol sobre el suelo es lamentable
pero finalizado con esto y volviendo al
tema inicial como les dije no sólo nos
referimos a mala praxis médica cuando
hablamos de un caso de un paciente con
un par de tijeras olvidadas en el medio
del estómago o en un error simple pero
catastrófico comerciales con tracción
buena mala prescripción de un
medicamento o remedio como quieran
llamarlo no también nos referimos a la
mala praxis médica al hablar de un
maltrato que se produce entre un
profesional y su paciente
a rasgos un poco generales diferentes
caminos pueden llevar a la mala praxis
médica
uno de ellos que podríamos hacer
podríamos decir que es el principal y
creo que en esto vamos a estar de
acuerdo es que no hay verdaderos
profesionales
sabemos que las diferentes carreras
dentro de un ámbito de salud son un poco
difíciles y requieren de dedicación y
esfuerzo y muchos de los estudiantes que
se encuentran dentro de ella están allí
más por la remuneración económica que
por la verdadera pasión de poder ayudar
a otros
y eso es lamentable pero es aún más
peligroso porque ellos en algún momento
van a tener que actuar por sí mismos y
lo harán en base de qué
otro de estos caminos que también
terminan en un callejón sin salida y
completamente oscuros es que puede que
sí llegar aún a cumplir con su formación
universitaria lo hicieron por sus medios
y por sus esfuerzos pero en ese camino
se olvidaron de algo completamente
fundamental sus valores de esa empatía
que ellos deberían de sentir por sus
pacientes y son estos los que son cada
vez más enterrados un ejemplo de esto
podríamos verlos en más de personas
avanzadas de edad
ancianas abuelitos y abuelitas llegan a
un punto en que se niegan a visitar un
médico y algunas veces nace por el
maltrato que ellos pudieron recibir
es verdad los ancianitos requieren de un
poquito más de paciencia y cuidado pero
se supone que para esto están
capacitados los médicos
hipócrates dijo dondequiera que haya
amor por la medicina también hay un amor
por la humanidad ya no hay personas
estudiando para la atención sanitaria
hay máquinas que se preocupan más por
las enfermedades y luego por los
pacientes no debería de ser al revés
otros sabios de apellido osler lo dijo
es más importante saber qué tipo de
paciente tiene una enfermedad a saber
qué tipo de enfermedad tiene un paciente
aún así no está todo perdido
estoy segura de que hay personas que
marcan una verdadera diferencia que
todos conocemos casos de personas dentro
de este ámbito que dieron un poco más de
sí personalmente vi uno de ellos un
médico amigo de la familia tiene una
destacada personalidad es un médico más
que capacitado pero aún así se destaca
más por el amor que emplean su trabajo
él atendió y atiende a personas que
capaz no tengan una obra social que no
puedan pagar la consulta o que no puedan
seguir sosteniendo su tratamiento
aún así decide seguir atendiéndolos y
capas lo haga con mejor dedicación que a
otros y eso es lo admirable que lo haga
sin esperar nada a cambio algo que hoy
en día es raro
entonces no no dejemos que esto no siga
perjudicando hoy veo rostros jóvenes veo
potenciales ojos que esto de la mala
praxis no sólo ocurre en un ámbito
médico hoy pongo hincapié en esto pero
ocurre en todos lados lamentablemente
aún así hay tiempo hay vidas y hay
motivos por los cuales empezar y cambiar
no dejemos que esto no siga perjudicando
o afectando a otros sabe en cuántos
casos de mala praxis médica hay por año
en la argentina se estiman de cinco mil
a seis mil y estos porcentajes son de un
estudio realizado seis meses sigue
subiendo estudiar enfermería medicina
promotor de salud asistencia médica es
dedicar tu vida para salvar o ayudar a
otros
en conclusión y me gustaría terminar con
esto como lo han dicho varios
comentaristas autores como lo he
mencionado también anteriormente en
todos los ámbitos de la vida aún más en
ámbitos médicos se requiere de más
humanidad más valores más amor entonces
nuestro deber o papel en todo esto sería
que hagamos uso de ellos como todos
dicen que mejor medicina que el amor
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]